salut à tous et le cdh reut après des
jours entiers avoir attendu l'arrivée
l'annoncé officielle de ce galaxy note
9/10 djiko toute son équipe nous ont
enfin officialisé ce smartphone est bien
plus que ce smartphone le note 9 est un
événement mais tout le reste est aussi
important et justement j'ai tout vous
dévoiler tout vous dire maintenant
le galaxy note 9 était attendue depuis
très longtemps on va pas se mentir on a
beaucoup parlé
il était extrêmement tendue parce que
c'est vrai que dès que samsung ou des
marques comme apple font des événements
des keynotes et présente de nouveaux
produits sont toujours des événements
parce que il donne un peu le pouls de la
technologie on s'attendait pas à voir un
produit révolutionnaire avec ce nom 9 on
s'entendait vraiment avoir une évolution
similaire à ce qu'on a eu entre le f8 et
le s9 et c'est au final ce qu'on a eu
une évolution entre le note 8 et le note
9 mai c'était très intéressant est ce
qui est primordial la danse et qu'on va
vraiment elle a une ligne directrice
dans laquelle va à samsung avec des
objets entièrement connectée et surtout
un écosystème global et c'est ça qui est
passionnant avec au centre une
intelligence artificielle et des
partenariats forts ça je vous développez
dans un second temps mais tout de suite
on va parler du samsung galaxy note 9
qui au final a tout l'air d'être un
excellent smartphone mais ça je vous
invite à vous abonner dès maintenant
parce qu'on va le tester d'ici quelques
temps dès qu'il sortira on va le prendre
en main on va le tester au val secoue un
peu tous les côtés on va voir si
effectivement ce nouveau hespel est
intéressant et toutes les
fonctionnalités qui vont en découler
le déjà d'un point de vue design se note
9 ne change pas forcément il n'a pas
tranché avec lui nos de suite c'est pas
non plus ce qu'on attendait de lui en
inde écran qui est légèrement plus grand
on passe de 6 points 3 pouces à 6 24
pouces
on a toujours un écran super amoled
format 18 points 5/9 des bords incurvés
une définition quad hd de 1960 par 1440
pixels une résolution de 5 114 ppp et on
le sait l'écran sera juste une bombe
atomique
ce sera juste l'un des meilleurs écrans
du marché actuel le design reste
standard capteur d'empreintes digitales
à l'arrière placé sous le module caméra
plus faciles à trouver et moins de
traces de doigts sur le capteur on
retrouve en bas et l'usb titre c'est
l'emplacement pour ranger votre hespel
toujours un port jack ça c'est plutôt
bien que ça me semblait pas enlever haut
parleurs à kg et là où c'est intéressant
c'est la performance
on garde le même processeur que les
snuff en exil aux 9810 rock d'accord et
danser jusqu'à 2,7 giga hertz tout ça
couple est assis giga de ram
samsung a vraiment mis en avant la
puissance dédié
au gamer faut savoir que l'exil aux 9810
tout comme le snapdragon 845 nous comme
le quirinal 170 sont actuellement les
processeurs les plus puissants marchés
donc pour les expériences de gaming ça
va vraiment faire la faire il ya un
partenariat fort qu été mis en place
j'en avais déjà parlé il ya quelque
temps c'est de pouvoir retrouver
fortnight en exclusivité sur android
avec ce galaxy note 9 et nous annonce un
cpu plus puissant de 33% des
performances améliorées et donc une
expérience que ce soit en utilisation de
jeu ce soir utilisation quotidienne bien
meilleure c'est d'ailleurs tout leur
teasing qu'elle était photos de ça
d'ailleurs à tizi qui a été fait autour
d'une meilleure longévité meilleure
autonomie au niveau de la batterie on
passe d'une batterie de trois mille
trois cent millions terreur les manières
sur le dos de fuite avec batterie de
4000 millions terreur sur ce fameux note
on voit que samsung a vraiment fait
oublier tout l'air et tous les problèmes
note 7 pour cette fois ci arrivait
encore plus fort mais revenir encore
plus fort avec ce produit en termes de
stockage est disponible en version
minimum avec 128 go de stockage ou alors
carrément en 512 il ya de stockage que
vous pouvez monter extensible jusqu'à 1
tera avec une carte de 512 gia autant
dire vrai pouvoir stocker tout ce que
vous voulez et ça c'est vraiment top en
terme de photos vidéos ou autres le
double capteur arrière deux fois 12
mégapixels vous à pouvoir faire des
photos avec une ouverture de f
1.5 donc excellent en faible luminosité
ou alors faire des photos avec une
ouverture de f 2.4 ça ça sera idéal
lorsque vous avez une excellente lumière
d'extérieur ou de studio pourquoi pas un
autofocus dualpix elle voudrait pouvoir
filmer jusqu'en nuages dès qu'on pouvait
faire du super slow motion en 960 images
par seconde et bien évidemment tout ça
booste et avec de l'intelligence
artificielle de la reconnaissance de
scène reconnaissance d'objets dont des
photos complètement optimisé il croyait
moi vu qu reprend les caractéristiques
photo du s9 s9 plus enthousiastes 9 plus
vous allez vraiment avoir un photophone
qui va être vraiment excellent dans ce
galaxy note 9 donc si vous voulez
vraiment un appareil dédié à la photo
pouvait aller dessus sans aucun problème
et l avant vous y retrouver une caméra
de 8 mégapixels qui sera parfaite pour
faire des selfs y ait des appels via
skype
il tourne
android 8.1 oreo avec une surcouche
expérience 8 9.0 et la deûle usb type
c'est une prise jack sadjo déjà dit du
bluetooth 5.0 une certification ip68 et
vous pouvez également logé une double
carte sim à l'intérieur et le point fort
du galaxy note 9 c'est avant tout le s
pen pourquoi acheter sinon un galaxy
note 9 grand format pour ne pas profiter
de son stylet et se respecte continue
d'évoluer il s'étale et nous propose une
fonction bluetooth
vous pouvez donc le connecter
directement en bluetooth à votre
smartphone pour l'utiliser comme une
télécommande vous l'utiliser avec un
appui cours un double appui un appui
long sur permettra d'avoir des fonctions
dédiées pour tout ce que vous voulez
faire vos de piloter pour de la musique
sur spotify ils ont d'ailleurs annoncé
un partenariat avec spotify vous pouvez
naviguer dans vos vidéos sur youtube
vous pouvez déclencher pour prendre les
photos à distance ça s'est vraiment bien
il y avait effectivement la
reconnaissance de gestes non va encore
plus loin mais également pour les
orientations provia powerpoint
on voit que ce espagne propose de
nouvelles fonctionnalités avec un
environnement complet et on imagine
qu'on préfère encore plein de choses
avec tout ça on va tester très
prochainement donc vous avez une fois de
plus à rester connectés et à vous
abonner aspen qui se recharge en
rentrant directement dans galaxy note 9
et qui se recharge en pas moins de 40
secondes
autre point très intéressant on avait
déjà parlé également il ya pas très
longtemps c'est l'arrivée d'un decs
nouvelle génération si vous vous
souvenez
le dext comme on l'a eue avec le n8 le
s9 et le nom de soutien dernière vous
aviez votre petit boîtier vous posiez
votre smartphone dessus et vous pouvez
vous connecter directement un moniteur
l'inconvénient c'est que ça vous oblige
et toujours à avoir ce petit boîtier
donc en gros vous aviez un beau leader
chez vous votre boîtier vous lui posiez
et ça vous bloquez vraiment pour
l'utiliser que chez vous et uniquement
chez vous c'est pas très pratique ce don
fait d'avoir un boîtier à chaque fois ou
alors emmené son boîtier chaque fois là
par contre samsung a vraiment revu sa
copie et ça c'est vraiment intéressant
ils ont fait le constat que votre
smartphone était aussi puissant qu'un
ordinateur donc vous aviez un petit
ordinateur directement dans votre
smartphone et vous allez avoir un
adaptateur usb type c hdmi pour le
brancher directement un moniteur comme
ça votre note 9 se transforme
directement en un ordinateur ils ont
fait des démonstrations relativement
intéressante sans reconnaître ou
effectivement vous allez pouvoir la voir
en mode
heures sans votre moniteur vous et
pouvoir continuer à naviguer dans votre
smartphone à regarder autre chose dessus
envoyer des messages en gardant toujours
le côté ordi et ça c'est plutôt
intéressant
c'est un produit qui en précommande dès
aujourd'hui il est disponible tarifs
2009 euros pour la configuration 128
giga et 1259 euros pour la version 512
giga et il sera livrable à partir du 24
août prochain
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je vous
ai mis des liens en bas dans la
description n'hésitez pas à passer par
eux si vous souhaitez réserver dès
aujourd'hui
mais samsung s'est pas contenté de nous
présenter uniquement uniquement
uniquement un galaxy note 9 cette fois
ci ils nous ont également introduit une
montre connecter la galaxie watch dispo
en 42 ou en 46 mm résistante à l'eau
bien évidemment corning gorilla glass ya
pas mal de fonctionnalités et de
spécifications hyper intéressante mais
ça on en reparlera plus en détails plus
tard parce que ceux ci et vous présentez
un peu les différents comment connecter
du moment c'est le couac qui lui
paraissent intéressantes
point intéressant au dessus des 2 caps
et world series 3 dernières vous pouvez
la brancher directement enquête j'ai ce
qui fait que si vous n'avez pas votre
iphone vous avez quand même pouvoir
communiquer et ça c'est plutôt
intéressant et mise en avant tout la
gestion du stress donc dans un univers
plus professionnel toujours le côté
santé bien évidemment la santé
prédictive encore pareil parce que c'est
aussi quelque chose de très intéressant
on va tous ces objets connectés sont là
pour vous aider à améliorer votre santé
le côté sport fitness bien évidemment
qui toujours mis en avant
l'analyse du sommeil tellement faim il
ya pas mal de choses mais tout ça on
développera ultérieurement mais surtout
est ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est l'arrivée de leurs enceintes
connectés qui s'appelle galaxie aung
alex young en quelque sorte un amazon
est qu un google home ou alors encore un
homme pote d'apple c'est donc une
enseigne connecter avec pas moins de six
haut parleurs à kg donc complètement
unidirectionnelle un seul bouffeurs pour
me dire envoyer un peu grave des micros
intégrés pour venir analyser votre pièce
savoir où vous pouvez signer dans la
pièce pour vraiment optimisé le son par
rapport à votre placement ça on retrouve
déjà dans le home pote d'apple et non
pas mal dans cinq connectés mais là où
samsung va beaucoup plus loin et ce qui
est vraiment intéressant et là où est
leur force de frappe c'est leur
écosystème complet parce que samsung ne
fabrique pas que des smartphones des
mondes connectés ou alors maintenant une
enceinte collecter fabrique des machines
à laver il fabrique des réfrigérateurs
fabrique des téléviseurs des tablettes
mais énormément de
un écosystème complet pour vous
permettre d'avoir vraiment un ensemble
complet samsung connectés et je me fais
encore la démonstration avec une vraie
force de frappe
je montrais leurs nouveaux partenaires
spotify spotify qui est une plateforme
de musique en ligne suppose que vous
connaissez qui est vraiment génial c'est
pas que vous écoutez votre musique sur
spotify sur votre smartphone vous
arrivez chez vous hop
elle passe sans votre qu'allez vous vous
rapprochez notre enceinte vous appuyez
dessus la musique passant votre enceinte
donc quel que soit l'endroit vous êtes
dans votre maison vous allez retrouver
votre musique sur spotify votre
information qui s'affiche aussi sans
votre réfrigérateur enfin c'est un
exemple qui peut paraître un peu débile
en se disant est ce que j'ai besoin
d'avoir de la musique partout si je les
vends mon smartphone ou dans un cadre
dans les écouteurs ou dans une enceinte
c'est largement suffisant mais ça
illustre vraiment la stratégie de
samsung et leur force de frappe sur une
vision globale de votre intérieur c'est
à dire pouvoir gérer complètement votre
vie numérique pour programmer votre
machine à laver est au travail
ou alors voir avec une caméra ce que
vous avez dans votre réfrigérateur
directement dans le smartphone ton étant
connecté en optimisant vous rendez vous
avec bixby l'ins artificielle qui sera
toujours plus de choses sur vous c'est
vraiment une vision de la vie connectée
du futur de samsung alors on n'y est pas
encore tout de suite mais on va y
arriver petit à petit objet connecté
après objets connectés
on va tous à un moment ou un autre
remplacer nos produits peut-être par des
pros du samsung peut être par d'autres
mais les objets deviennent de plus en
plus connectés en tout cas
interconnecter les autres et ça ça reste
quand même très intéressant je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez vous d'ailleurs dû
clairement comment ça mais moi je trouve
ça plutôt intéressant je vous ai déjà
sorti une vidéo dessus où j'ai été voir
les stands de samsung au ce1 début
d'année au mwc après oui mais vraiment
en avant tous ces objets connectés
cette interconnexion de tous ces objets
numériques et c'est vraiment intéressant
et vous allez voir dans les années à
venir
ça va se développer plus en plus on va
de plus en plus craints interconnecté
pas forcément de côté négatif on va
pouvoir craindre un flicage par exemple
votre marque souvent très fédérateur
sache exactement ce qu'il a à
l'intérieur que vous mangez ce que vous
mangez pas l'idée c'est pas ça mais
c'est vraiment de vous aider vous
assister dans votre quotidien et samsung
là dessus par rapport à d apple ou
huawei a vraiment un coup d'avancé la
marque qui est vraiment aussi
positionner là dessus c'est chiant
michaud lui qui est un cube énormément
de start up les qui une fois que les
produits sont intéressants et bien les
vents sous son nom alors aujourd'hui en
france l'offre est pas complètement
folle il arrive avec les smartphones les
tablettes et vous allez voir dans le
temps ça va vraiment développer et je
suis aussi une offre à 362 m tout ça on
en parlait intérieurement
voilà pour ces infos dites moi vous ce
que vous avez pensé en tout cas de la
présentation de ce galaxy note n'est pas
ce qui pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce qu'il vous tente est ce que vous
vous dites oui au final ce note 9 c'est
une évolution d'une autre tweet il
apporte pas des choses complètement
dingos a contrario est-ce qui vous a
bluffé est ce que vous pourriez être
tenté par ce conduit plus croyez moi
connaissant la qualité de samsung
l'écran est juste magnifique et les
photos vont être top j'ai pu tester les
snuff s9 plus eu croyez moi c'est
vraiment de la bombe atomique
marc climat tout ça commente anne moi ce
que vous en pensez on reste bien
évidemment connecté on va beaucoup
parler
je voulais le prendre en main on va le
tester dans la longueur d'ici quelques
temps donc vous allez une fois de plus à
rester connectés merci à vous d'être
toujours plus nombreux qui sont plus
nombreux on a passé enfin les soixante
mille abonnés merci à vous vous êtes
inscrit merci beaucoup j'espère que tout
ce que je vous fais le travail d'une
vidéo par jour vous plaît alors là je
vais prendre un peu de vacances
je vous en mets avec moi en crète on va
aller se faire dorer la pilule on va les
bronzes un peu mais rassurez vous il y
aura encore des vidéos que je tournerai
là bas j'ai quelque chose à vous montrer
donc on reste connectés merci à vous
autres et netto soyez sages
je vous embrasse son bouquin
[Musique]